if you were gonna tease the season to me
like in in just one sentence or
something with how different it's gonna
be the energy what would you tell
somebody
oh that's a good one okay um
hold on to your seat get ready for the
ride
and let's go brit it's happening
it's happening like
you are officially a pro on dancing with
the stars
how does saying that feel well
it feels real and also a relief because
i've just been
holding it in and
i am just i'm just so grateful
and i'm just so excited and
i'm just thrilled i'm over the moon
honestly ever since i found out
i don't really know what to do with
myself
so much excitement so much emotion i bet
you want to dance i bet you want to get
to it
oh yeah i mean the anticipation
is just boiling
well the thing is you're somebody who's
been beloved by fans for years there was
a petition
to get you to be a pro so why was it
shocked did you
think this might never happen well you
know
it's definitely been a goal of mine and
i think the shock just came from that
it's coming into reality and something
that i've been
hoping for and working for is just
really coming to
fruition and i know there's been this
like build up i was so happy to see my
girls on twitter such a petition
so sweet and so heartwarming and so i
think it was also the build-up of all
this
energy surrounding it too um
and then i also think too you know i was
away from the show
for a full year as well and um
which was great and i was able to learn
a lot in this year
so i think coming back after a full year
added to the shop as well
well again you're so talented the fans
love you you are just a ray of sunshine
and then on top of it i mean you're
you're making dancing with the stars
history here you are the first black
female pro
so how does that feel for you it feels
first to be the first black female pro
is such an honor i definitely don't take
it lightly
um i you know having this
opportunity and position is just
so beautiful and i'm so happy to
take it on and also be a part of a show
that celebrates diversity and you know
when i was there
for five seasons on trip and two tours i
always felt celebrated
for not just my race but for all of me
and um
so also being part of dance movie stars
that has that sort of
um love and openness for equality
is an honor as well we're doing all this
crazy stuff
taking it to the next level but still
like you know keeping the stuff that we
know america loves but you need to get
ready
because it's gonna be different i mean
this season is shaping up to be
i think it's gonna be a moment i mean
we've got you
and then now tyra banks a black woman
hosting the show
i don't know if you've talked to tyra at
all have you heard from her since this
news got announced
and how do you feel about that i haven't
heard from tyra but i cannot
wait her personality and her energy
is just so big and so magnificent
and i really think it's going to bring
this new energy
into the ballroom and i feel like you
know i'm part of that new energy
and i just think it's almost the perfect
time to
everything this season's going to look
really different and
i think there's no expectations and i
think that's
this amazing opportunity to just have
this new energy
and just all sorts of fantastic things
i mean tell me when you say this season
is going to look different
are we all going to be tuning in to a
new show what does that mean
i think that means that you're going to
see a lot of familiar things but then a
lot of things
that are different too especially with
coded
and the way that things will be
structured with that
i think it's just going to be new all
around and it's just going to be a
season like we've never seen
i think the most different thing is we
will not be able to have interaction
with the other pros and the other
couples so that i think will be the
biggest difference um you know we have
to stay
eight feet away from everybody else and
you know i'm really going to be in this
bubble with my partner which i think is
also kind of fun
because i'll really be able to create
this
great relationship with my partner to
last through hopefully
okay well i was gonna say what i'm
interested in is we've seen
the tension from the stress of dancing
with the stars between partners before
so what does being in a bubble with your
celebrity partner
do to that pro-partner relationship
could it amplify the tension it could
amplify but then i just think that's
when it's important to bring in balance
and bring in communication
and all of that of course being on a
competition show
there's going to be stress and all these
other things but yeah just staying
balanced and
i mean look i as a viewer i'm i'm kind
of interested in it like
i love the show we love how positive it
is but sometimes you like a little drama
so i'm okay with it
so what about what it will do to the
show that you can't
interact as much with everybody else
like will that
just again amp up the competition i
think it will
i think coming on mondays people
probably will not have
any idea what our fellow competitors
will be doing which you
oh because you used to watch each
other's rehearsals yeah and so i think
it'll bring a new level of excitement
and fun to it as well and mystery so
will you guys not tell each other
what the what the dances are because
yeah sometimes you'll pop your head into
everybody else's rehearsals
um i mean i think that we are all such a
close-knit family
that we will probably still be
communicating okay with facetime
and text and just even
just for support and well that's another
aspect how much will you miss
everybody that you don't get to be as
close as you usually are
i it's so funny i have um
i've talked to a few people and there's
just been so much support from my fellow
cast members texting me and
congratulating me
on my first season and i just i just
love them so much and i just keep
telling everyone that i cannot wait to
give them
the biggest hug in november just so far
what we know
as far as covet is concerned is
production is
taking our health extremely seriously
they are following and will be following
all of the necessary health precautions
and regulations in order for us to have
the most healthy and safe season
possible and
as of now that's really all we know i
mean i'm picturing
bedazzled masks is that an option
i mean we haven't heard about bedazzled
masks but i'm not
mad at it and where will you guys hole
up with your partner where will you be
at
as of now we'll just still be living
separately and then
the places um and then we'll just
be in a bubble within the studio really
yeah well because this is really a show
where the audience falls in love with
the pros and their personalities as well
as the celebrities
um now i gotta ask you we only know
for sure caitlyn bristow as a celebrity
cast member right now
what else have you heard do you have any
dream celebrity you'd love to be paired
with
you know it's so interesting i feel like
usually
you know being part of the show usually
there's some sort of cast rumors and
there's been nothing and we're in the
dark as well i have
no idea which makes the excitement and
the anticipation
even more i mean if we could get someone
like brad pitt
somebody from cheer would be absolutely
fantastic
and they would come in with that
athleticism already
and that personality and
i mean the biggest thing for me when it
comes to a partner is just
having someone with a really amazing
personality
hard worker and just like overall
positive attitude and then i'll be a
happy girl
okay what about a high school musical
celebrity i remember whitney saying she
wanted zac efron
which seems lofty but oh i mean zach
would be
brilliant i also think weakest gabriel
would be
amazing he is a natural mover
and we are going to be missing um
whitney and lindsay i don't know if
you've talked to them
missing them for great reasons because
they're they're both expecting
uh what do you think the show will be
like without them in the ballroom
because they've been there for a while
i first of all i am beyond happy for
whitney and lindsay
they're both really good friends of mine
and you know to not be
this is the perfect reason to not be a
part of the season you know they're
bringing
life into the world which is so
beautiful with magnificent
um and i really do think you know of
course they're going to be missed in the
ballroom they are both
staple female pros that have both
so much to offer individually um but you
know i think that
having sharna back and daniella is a
powerhouse
and so it's just a lot of new energy
that i think will bring
the season to be next level it's also
going to be really interesting
for the married dancing with the stars
pros
to not live together what will that do
to the dynamic
bless the married couples for having to
separate
this season um i think you know
all of the married couples are so strong
as couples and also as individuals and
so i think they will be
absolutely fine of course they're going
to miss each other but i think that's
good
who do you think will have the easiest
time being a part and who will have the
toughest time being apart
oh that's interesting i think
probably the easiest will be sasha and
emma
you know they've been married for a
while but they're also such
individual people in their own right um
even you know without being in a couple
and then i think probably
jenna and bow will have the hardest time
you know they're the newest to be
married and they're still in that
honeymoon
stage you posted a throwback video
of you dancing uh when you were a lot
younger
and enjoying this moment right now
soaking it all in
what would you tell that little girl
about where she's going to end up in her
dancing
career
um
now this is when i get a little
emotional
um i would tell that little girl that
no matter what anything is possible and
to never be afraid to reach for the
highest possibility
ever did that little girl think this was
possible
that little girl did not think that this
was possible
i you know and i don't even know if it
was because of circumstance it just
sometimes you don't know how high you
can reach until you get to a certain
place
and then you see it and you see it be
tangible or you see someone that looks
like you
that is doing it and then you realize
it's possible
i know tyra is the new host and you're
really excited but you did spend years
with with tom and with aaron have you
heard from them at all a congratulations
or anything
i've spoken with tom not since the news
but um i've spoken with him in the last
month and
you know he is amazing he's an amazing
man and amazing at what he does
and he really did amazing things for
dancing with the stars and i am just so
excited to see where he goes next
because
you know he he really is fantastic and
he's
he's going to be around on tv i am not
worried about
it all right well if you were gonna
tease the season to me like in
in just one sentence or something with
how different it's gonna be the energy
what would you tell somebody
oh that's a good one okay um
hold on to your seat get ready for the
ride
and let's go all right i gotta wrap with
you but very quickly
who do you consider your biggest
competition pro wise
pro rise um i would probably have to say
sharna is my chicken she's back only
because she's
back she's a fan favorite and i love
that girl and she is
fire she's going to be back with a
[Music]
vengeance